herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren ja wie würden sie reagieren wenn
ihr bester freund ihnen gestehen würde
eigentlich sei er kein mann sondern eine
frau so genannte trans personen werden
in unserer gesellschaft immer noch
stigmatisiert und diskriminiert
warum tun wir uns so schwer damit mit
menschen die ihr körperliches geschlecht
als unpassend empfunden
und warum gibt es eigentlich nur die
kategorien mann und frau und nichts
dazwischen
über diese fragen sprechen ich heute mit
zwei gästen die nicht nur ausgewiesene
expertinnen sind sondern auch betroffene
michelle baeriswyl ist psychologin
sexualpädagogik und kultur philosophie
und sie leitet die sprechstunde für
gender variante menschen in st gallen
hannes rudolph ist psychologie und
theaterregisseur gründungsmitglied des
transgender network switzerland und
leiter der zürcher fachstelle für trans
menschen herzlich willkommen in beiden
die anderen ja wenn in meinem umfeld ein
baby zur welt kommt dann ist eine der
ersten fragen die gestellt werden immer
ist es ein junge oder ein mädchen
stellen sie die stellen sie diese frage
auch also wem jetzt machst du ich
persönlich stelle die frage nicht fragt
immer ob es gesund ist und meistens ja
dann irgendwie einnahmen da ist dann
meistens die markierung schon da wenn
dem ich jetzt dringend interessiert aber
wenn der name uneindeutig ist dann frage
ich auch erstmal nicht nach
vielleicht nicht so relevant bei ihm
also was meine kinder zur welt kommen
wollen wir das eigentlich relativ
wurscht welches geschlecht die haben
sondern dass sie gesund sind
danach geht es ja eigentlich dann los je
nachdem wen man da ein junge ist dann
gibt es halt lange kleider und autos und
wenn es ein mädchen ist rosa kleider und
puppen vielleicht warum machen wir das
ein warum spielt das geschlecht eine so
wichtige rolle
kultur als ich meine diese farb
zuordnung die ist ja hat sich gewechselt
es war nicht immer so dass klink oder
rosa rot für die mädchen ist hellbraun
für die uns diese geschlechts marke
schon bei der geburt finde ich schon
unglaublich dass diese
zweigeschlechtlichkeit schon bei geburt
derart zelebriert werden muss hat er
somit mit wirtschaftlichen aspekten zu
tun weil wir dann irgendwie zweimal die
kleider kaufen kann
ich würde sagen sendermarken hat sich da
ein gehängt weil sie wirklich damit geld
machen können und gibt es heute abstruse
form von gender marketing
aber ich denke das ist viel älter das
hat mit gender marktprämie man nichts zu
tun
aber gibt es den kulturen oder gab es
zeiten wo das anders ist das geschlecht
weniger wichtiger als heute
also ich bin zum beispiel in der ddr
aufgewachsen und da war es durchaus so
so in den 80er jahren das zum beispiel
schon aus wirtschaftlichen gründen weil
geschwister verschiedenen geschlechts
die gleichen kleider getragen haben und
mit den gleichen dingen gespielt haben
diese rosa hellblau zuordnung so krass
nicht wahr
also ich glaube schon dass die rolle von
von gender marketing eine entscheidende
spielt weil warum mussten fahrer hatten
mädchen oder jungs fahrrad sein das war
jahrzehntelang nicht so und das ist
einerseits weil wir es uns leisten
können und andererseits weil offenbar
auch das interesse besteht das so
geschlechtsspezifisch zu verkaufen
also wir wollen heute so ein bisschen
über dieses geschlecht sprechen über das
biologische geschlecht aber auch über
das soziale geschlecht das heißt über
die geschlechterrollen
wir wollen über trance identität
sprechen über trans frauen und trans
männer und wenn man sich mit dem thema
nicht so vertraut ist dann kommt man
schnell mal durcheinander wir haben
einen einspieler vorbereitet der die
wichtigsten begriffe einfach und
verständlich erklärt
[Musik]
es ist ein mädchen oder hurra es ist ein
junge auf geburtsanzeigen nie fehlen
darf der name das gewicht und natürlich
das geschlecht des sprösslings
dieses wird auch gleich in der
geburtsurkunde vermerk rosa oder
hellblau weiblich oder männlich
aber was wenn das geschlecht nicht fix
ist bei trans menschen stimmt dass bei
der geburt zugeordnete körperliche und
amtliche geschlecht nicht wird der
geschlechtsidentität über ein unter dem
körperlichen geschlecht besteht man eine
ansammlung von verschiedenen aspekten
äußere und innere geschlechtsorgane kein
drüsen hormone chromosomen und weitere
sekundäre geschlechtsmerkmale ob
weiblich oder männlich diese einteilung
erfolgt bei der geburt meistens nur über
die äußeren geschlechtsmerkmale und
bestimmt danach das amtliche geschlecht
sie einen menschen mit einem angeborenen
weiblichen körper der sich aber männlich
fühlt nennt man trans mann
einen menschen mit einem ursprünglich
männlichen körper der sich weiblich
freund nennt man trans frau trans
menschen können hetero- homo- oder
bisexuell sein oder eine andere sexuelle
orientierung haben mit ihrer
geschlechtsidentität hat dies nichts zu
tun auch wichtig trans menschen sind
nicht transvestiten auch drag queens
oder crosstrainer genannt ja bei der
vorbereitung auf diese sendung habe ich
gemerkt dass man schnell ins
fettnäpfchen tritt oder betroffene
verletzt wenn man die falschen fragen
gestellt oder die falschen begriffe
verwendet was sollte man dann auf keinen
fall fragen oder sagen es geht gar nicht
so sehr um befindlichkeiten nur das
thema sprache es ja auch ein thema was
was mit macht zu tun hat wie ich über
sachen reden wie ich über menschen rede
wer bestimmt dass ich finde es mir
wichtig dass leute die von was betroffen
sind also wie jetzt in unserem fall
trans personen selber sagen so oder so
soll über uns gesprochen werden
das ist legitim dass es auch im bereich
rassismus legitim oder wenn es um
menschen mit behinderung geht zum
beispiel ganz wichtig im bereich trans
ist dass man einen punkt erfasst nämlich
den wir haben es jetzt um einen spieler
gesehen dass geschlechtsidentität
entscheidend es oder maßgeblich für das
geschlecht von den menschen also wir
reden von trans man trans frau es gibt
noch weitere trans personen die er so
nicht genannt worden aber da kommen wir
vielleicht später drauf und wir reden
entsprechend der geschlechtsidentität
früher hat die medizin zum beispiel zu
trans frauen gesagt das sind
transsexuelle männer weil sie sind von
diesem biologismus ausgegangen von
dieser biologischen zuordnung und das
hat es war wirklich wie ein wandel im
verständnis was ist trans überhaupt zu
akzeptieren und anzuerkennen dass man
dem thema nicht beikommt wenn man nicht
versteht dass das geschlecht von trans
menschen die identität ist nicht der
körper und das ist nicht um die sexuelle
orientierung geht wasserberg
transsexuell so müssten dringend stärken
das ist die zweite grund warum die
vokabel auch so irreführend ist und
warum es gut dass die nicht zu benutzen
gibt es sonst dinge die verletzend sind
die man nicht sagen sollte aber trotzdem
ist es irgendwie
hört man das oft aus betroffen das ist
ein richtig wenn jemand sich nicht
sicher ist wie soll ich diese person
ansprechen
man kann ja fragen wir antworten auf die
wichtigsten fragen kommen ja auch immer
und diese verunsicherung ist ja auch
bemerkbar was ich dann eher mühsam finde
ist wenn wenn ich klarmachen wie ich
angesprochen werden möchte und die
andere person blockt ab und sagte nee
das geht für mich nicht weißt du ich
kenne ich noch von früher
darum kommt bei mir hat immer wieder ein
er hervor und so ich finde ich lasse
meinen leuten zeit ich habe ihnen viel
zeit gelassen aber irgendwann der
zeitpunkt wo ich finde entweder zeigst
du mir der respekt gegenüber hörst so
was ich dir sage und dahinter das
einfach nicht kannst dann breche ich die
beziehung ab und das musste ich mit
relativ vielen menschen machen das
stichwort respekt ist es genau der punkt
das gegenüber trans menschen das
korrekte pronomen benutzt wird das ist
so eine sache dass man zum beispiel von
adtranz frauen nicht als ein mann der
eine frau sein will spricht das ist ganz
solche dinge
und da das mag leuten die die sich an
dem thema nicht auskennt spitzfindig
vorkommen aber es geht am ende darum bin
ich ein mann oder werde ich als eine
frau die irgendwas darstellt irgendwas
spielt so tut als wir sind man
wahrgenommen und sie waren schon immer
einmal das ist auch wichtig nicht wie
sie waren früher mal eine genaue oder
sie waren waren man das ist genau das
was ich schon immer noch frau war weiß
ich nicht
simon der ba werden nicht als frau
geboren sind zur frau gemacht
ich denke da hat es schon ein bisschen
spieler waren denn als ich will nicht
sagen
ich habe mich schon immer aus frau
gefühlt aber ich habe aber einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt gemerkt dass ich
das was man mit männlichkeit in dieser
gesellschaft verbindet dass ich das
nicht bin
und das war nicht einfach von der
gefühls frage sondern das war ganz tief
drehen ich bin das nicht aber das heißt
nicht dass ich mit sechs jahren dann der
frau war sondern einfach ich fühlte mich
anders aber ich hatte keine begriffe der
begriff transsexuell den sondern nicht
so lange gibt habe ich damals nicht
gekannt und das ist auch gut so weil das
ein pathologischer begriff aus medizin
und psychiatrie transsexuell transsexual
ismus ist ein reiner begriff hast
medizin und psychiatrie und
anbeginn hoch pathologisierung und trans
identisch oder trans identität ist zum
beispiel so ein alternativ begriff der
von vielen leuten benutzt wird tanz
geschlechtlich ist auch ein guter
begriff transgender aus dem englischen
sprachraum ist europay und ich sage
heute ich einfach nur trans ich meine
wenn man an sich entdeckt dass man mir
dass man trans ist dann kann ich mir
vorstellen wenn dann noch die begriffe
fehlen ist es sehr schwierig man spürt
dass man nicht anders ist können da die
gräfin konzept ja auch helfen
ja natürlich in dem moment wo es für
eine bestimmte sache keinen namen gibt
kann ich nicht wahrnehmen dass ich so
bin also zum beispiel homosexualität
wurde ja früher auch als die liebe die
keinen namen hat oder sowas oder das
gefühl dass keinen namen hat bezeichnet
erst in dem moment wo mir klar ist dass
das eine bezeichnung für was gibt kann
ich das überhaupt denken wobei es
interessant ist dass zum beispiel trans
kinder ohne diese ganzen konzepte zu
kennen einfach zum teil ganz klar ihre
identität äußern
die sagen dann einfach ich bin ein
junger obwohl man die geburt zuordnung
eine andere war und die ihn kennen den
begriff trans nicht und die wissen
natürlich dass es geschlechtsidentität
gibt noch zwei drei spiele nicht direkt
mich interessiert noch die dass der
punkt der pathologisierung also bei
homosexualität war das lange aus
krankheit aus störung klassifizierte
medizinisch beitragen die identität ist
das heute länder dies vorher ja es gibt
es zwei verschiedene diagnose systeme
und in dem von der amerikanischen
assoziation von dem psychiater innen
heißt das center des vw und in der
klassifikation von der whu wird es
wahrscheinlich als gender inkongruenz
erscheinen wenn die neue version raus
ist da steht es im moment immer noch in
den psychischen störungen wo es nicht
hingehört und interessant ist aber dass
dieser begriff für sich ändern also ist
die medizin sehr kreativ das neue
begriffe findet um auf gesellschaftliche
reaktionen strukturen veränderungen zu
reagieren
also ich haben homosexualität ist im
im dsm was einem diesem dieser
qualifikationen systeme ist es im 1971
ausgefallen
erst 1980 interessanterweise kam etwas
zu diesem zeitpunkt trans hinein
also wir haben da ein bisschen ein
schichtwechsel homosexualität wurde ein
pathologisiert und trans kamera ein und
wir sind jetzt historische an dem punkt
wo das mit der transsexualität langsam
wieder rausfliegt wie fest werden wir
noch sehen ist geschichtlich interessant
wir haben uns im vorfeld der sendung ein
bisschen unter die leute begeben sind
auf die straße gegangen und haben über
dieses thema diskutiert und eine frage
die wir gestellt haben war
wenn sie sich einordnen müssten sich in
einer skala von 1 bis 10 1 wäre so
typisch männlich ganz männlich sehen wir
ganz weiblich ganz fahren wo würden sie
sich einordnen und die antworten waren
sehr interessant was ich für mich
gefunden
[Musik]
wieso
ja ich habe mich noch nicht damit
beschäftigt aber ich bete seine zufolge
sind ja mega filmen müsste man lässt und
können sie das auch begründen
man fühlt sich mit seiner frau genommen
im normalfall sein jahre hormon und
genen und alles oder sehen meistens
schon vor gebot dürfe sogar eine mini
haben wie vale inter sieht der kasseler
polizei und erklär und akzeptiere dass
beide seiten in ihrer ganz stark vor
allem anita khmer toni alleinerziehend
und weitere haben wir so nicht eben
reifer frauen besorgten oder wenn ich so
fahre skala von 1 bis 10
es war ganz ganz lang und zwar ganz
üblich wo er studiert
[Musik]
aber ich würd ich bin mir mögliche
nordsee und das ich für mich also wird
sind für mich spielt das mega wie black
stars ist ein richtiger mal richtige
frau ja gut ausschaut und durchführt
matif die aggression also wohl nicht
unbedingt destruktiv ist sondern er ist
zumindest mein gestürzter polizisten und
frau nur zu vereinen die kooperation
ich habe einmal spielen
ein fußballspieler damit auch dass die
sachen die er macht ich bin ein ganz
männlich oder machen sie das fest ja
weil ich mag frauen und männer nicht
sehr einfach ist es so einfach es ist
großartig ich finde es ein ganz ganz
hervorragenden ein spieler weil da
derzeit 2 nach dem ersten die leute sind
nicht gewöhnt dass man diese frage
stellt man weiß gar nicht wie mir sein
geschlecht begründen können und dass das
schön das passiert normalerweise vor
allem trance menschen das geschlecht
begründen sollen
und hier haben sie den spieß mal
umgedreht das finde ich sehr schön und
der zweite punkt ist was zehn leute
heran um ihre männlichkeit und
weiblichkeit zu begründen
und da haben wir was was zum thema trans
überhaupt keine rolle spielt aber oft
genannt wird wenn wir so über geschlecht
reden landläufig das macht auch so ein
großes missverständnis häufig aus das
eine ist sexuelle orientierung ob ich
auf männer oder auf frauen stehe das hat
sagt gar nichts darüber aus wie ich mich
selber identifizieren es gibt der schule
es gibt ja wie es gibt ja lesbisch also
sagen dass das alles als richtiger
worden genau wie man frauen genau und
das erklärt aber natürlich auch warum
die situation von gleichgeschlechtlichen
beziehungen auch immer noch sehr
schwierig ist weil das so ein grund zu
sein scheint im denken sondern gesellt
haben und dann kommen als zweites die
stereotype mit denen sie ja auch
eingestiegen waren und das ist das
größte missverständnis was über trans
meine meinung nach kursiert das trans
menschen gerne ein bestimmtes sehr
youtube leben wollen und dass deswegen
machen oder also dass diese idee dass
das trans menschen die diese soziale
geschlecht zum beispiel wechseln damit
sie ein bestimmtes rollenbild leben
können
und das trifft einfach nicht zu
natürlicher manche dann auch spaß daran
irgendwie rollenbilder zu leben aber der
punkt warum man das macht es nicht weil
man irgendwas bestimmt das leben will
sondern weil man sich
in dem geschlechter in dem man bei der
geburt zugewiesen wurde nicht passend
findet und ich kann ich kann als trans
personen genauso sein
also ich habe es leuten immer so erklärt
ich könnte die gleiche person die ich
bin auch als frau sein
der einzige unterschied ist dass ich
keine frau bin von den ställen typen her
ob ich bier träge oder ob ich kleine
kinder toll finde oder sowas
das hat spielt keine rolle für diese
identität genau die die rauen diese
spiele kann aber der körper spielt schon
eine rolle also wenn ich mich jetzt als
frau fühlen würde dann möchte ich auch
einen bayerischen körper also ich könnte
sagen ich fühle mich als frau aber ich
muss nicht wie eine frau aussehen oder
oder leben
aber das ist nicht dran spezifisch also
dass ich geschlecht auch irgendwo am
körper fest macht das das ist ja für
alle menschen evident und der zweite
aspekt ist
sie haben ein bisschen nachgefragt weil
die leute geben die antworten von
irgendwo bei 1 und irgendwo bei 10 gehen
ein bisschen in die mitte damit nicht
ganz so krass ausfällt und das
interessant ist eben wenn man danach
fragt ja was was sind denn indikatoren
für weiblichkeit für männlichkeit dann
landen alle bei den stereotyp und dann
sind da sind die trans mensch der nicht
ausgeschlossen davon auch wir leben in
dieser gesellschaft wir wären durchleben
diese die diese spannungen auf
vielleicht sogar viel haut mehr als die
meisten menschen
es kommen nur stereotypen und
interessant wenn ich auch die miete war
wieder ausgesperrt und das ist so mein
mein punkt dass wir haben keinen
sozialen raum zwischen den geschlechtern
der belebt ist und trans menschen sind
vielleicht menschen die fromme sichtbar
sind so wie ich aus thrones wir beleben
diesen sozialen lehrer also wir sind
sichtbar sind angreifbar und dieses
leben dazwischen das ist hoch
anstrengend das braucht viel energie und
da verstehe ich viele trans
geschlechtliche personen die dann halt
einfach von dieser sichtbarkeit weg
wollen und viel anpassungsleistung
bringen an die gesellschaft um nicht
mehr sichtbar zu sein
es braucht viel energie wie werden
später noch über solche menschen
sprechen die sich ja auch wieder
ausbauen auch unser land führen
oder vielleicht biologisch nicht
eindeutig sind sogenannte intersexuelle
jetzt interessiert mich noch wie merkt
man aus tanz personen denn dass man
trans ist woran zeigt sich das für einen
selbst wann haben sie gemerkt dass die
zustände sind
ich glaube ich habe mir das eben nie
wirklich gefragt weil ich nicht die
ausnahme gewesen sondern eher die regel
aber ich irgendwie muss ja was passieren
also hat man andere fantasien zieht man
vielleicht mal sich eher so an ihren
mann oder was was hinzu ich finde die
frage berechtigt weil
geschlechtsidentität ist ja für cis
personen eigentlich kaum wahrnehmbar
also wenn ich selber als kind gesagt
kriege du hast das und das geschlecht
dazu gehört dass und das körperteil und
das passt für mich dann nämlich diese
passen dann nämlich diese existenz von
geschlechtsidentität gar nicht wahr und
es ist ja auch ein bedürfnis von trans
von trans menschen leuten zu erklären
wie kann man geschlechtsidentität
greifen und aus meiner beratungspraxis
kann ich sagen die allermeisten
schildern als irgendein gefühl von in
konkurrenz also was irgendwie merken
irgendwas stimmt nicht
immer wenn wir im kindergarten
aufgeteilt wurden in jungs und mädchen
hat mich das gefühl gehabt ich bin in
der falschen gruppe oder wenn die leute
gesagt haben du bist aber das mädchen
oder so dann habe ich mich immer nicht
passend gefühlt und so dieses nicht
passend fühlen und manche beschreiben es
auch wie ein gefühl im falschen film zu
sein so komplett in der realen welt
herum zu laufen bis sie das dann
irgendwann benennen können und dieses
gefühl von so real
zur realität aufhört ist jedem schönes
zitat von carolin emcke ist ja mal
gesagt solange du den moment spricht
darfst aber nicht dem irrtum erlegen das
ist diese normen nicht gibt und ich
glaube das macht diesen großen
unterschied aus wenn man der norm
entspricht
geht man davon aus es gibt keinen ort
was wir nennen sie auch hetero
normativität und zweigeschlechtlichkeit
es fällt nicht auf man gehört dazu und
von da an wo man merkt da gibt es eine
differenz irgendetwas passt nicht
hinterfragt man frauen natürlich auch
diese normen weil man irgendwo nicht
mehr ganz dazu passt und das ist in der
geschichte der homosexualität in
geschichte von von 20 menschen sehr
ähnlich sobald man nicht mehr passt muss
man sich fragen stellen
das heißt wir müssen uns erklären es ist
menschen heterosexuelle menschen müssen
sich eigentlich nicht erklären
sie ist menschen um das noch zu erklären
reisen dass ich mich in meinem
körperlichen geschlecht dass ich das was
posten empfindet als ich letztens ist
genauso schlechten sie denn titel stimmt
mit der zuordnung bei der geburt über
ein genau jetzt wirklich interessieren
kann man abschätzen wie viele trans
personen in der schweiz leben es ist
wahrscheinlich schwierig aber es gibt
schätzungen oder es gibt weil die
studien relativ schlecht vergleichbar
sind die so im internationalen raum
gemacht werden schätzen mit so zwischen
40.000 und was ist die neueste
obergrenzen schätzungen gewesen
200.000 habe ich schon gehört in der
schweiz ein bisschen definitions
abhängig haut auch darum
unterschiedliche resultate ich rekorde
jedoch zwei studien holland 2013
sprechen von 0 5 prozent das wären diese
40.000 darin wahl ins herz ja das ist
also in der schweiz wenn du hast du 40
sind relativ viele wenn man bedenkt dass
gibt 50.000 bauern was wir sind fast
gleich gross in der menge und bauen wie
games weniger bei uns gibt es
tendenziell mehr aus irgendwann werden
wir dabei stand haben und williams
institut usa 2016
die haben untersuchungen in
unterschiedlichen bundesstaaten gemacht
und da finde ich spannend dass die
resultate haben sehr groß variiert
zwischen 0,3 und 0,8 prozent und wenn
man da sich fragt wieso es hängt sehr
stark mit der gesetzgeber
zusammen und mit der präsenz des themas
politisch mit der sensibilisierung mit
der sensibilisierung ich meine wenn
nicht immer lassen die haben sexualität
verboten ist
dann gibt es keine homosexuellen haben
wage niemand so wie sich dann zu amten
die niederländische studie die fragt
identifizieren sie sich mit dem
geschlecht was ihnen bei der geburt
zugewiesen wurde
also was wirklich so eine minimal
definition das sagt nichts darüber aus
ob die person sich irgendwann mal lautet
ob sie darüber spricht ob sie das und
die soziale rolle wechselt geschweige
denn nutze geschlechts an gleichende
maßnahmen körperlich ergreift oder so
dass es wirklich nur minimal der filz
und jetzt hab' mir der forschung über
trans kinder gesprochen wie das sehr
früh merken und wir haben zwei sehr
eindrückliche beispiele vorbereitet und
schaden ist das kurze ich bin da wie ich
bin sechs jahre alt als ich zur welt kam
dachten sie ist ein mädchen
aber die ärzte hatten sich geirrt ich
mein junge
ich warte ich mach ein foto der fotos
denn ich bin es leid
das bin ich als ich noch sarah war
ich bin ein junge mit einer vagina ich
wusste dass ich ein junge war aber sie
haben mir nur zwischen die beine
geschaut
sie hatten mein gehirn vergessen das
sind alle kleider die ich in meinem
leben schon hatte das ist als
prinzessinnen kleid
das ist ein kleid von tinkerbell aber es
ging damals ein kleid vom aschenputtel
das ist ein bisschen klein
ich mochte sie weil sie für mädchen sind
diese prinzessinnen kleider als ich
klein war dachte ich wenn ich eine
prinzessin wäre dann würde mir die ganze
stadt gehören
als ich acht war wurde ich vom juni zum
mädchen
[Musik]
ich wollte kein junger sein die leute
müssen wissen dass es auch jungs mit
einer vagina und mädchen mit einem penis
geld ja diesen eindrückliche dokfilm
können sie noch einen monat lang auf
unserer website in voller länge sehen
ich habe mich beim betrachten dieses
films gefragt woher ist man also sicher
dass diese geschlechtsidentität stabil
bleibt meine diese kinder sind schon
noch sehr jung wir haben die pubertät
noch vor sich woher weiß man dass die
frage ist ob man sich so sicher sein
muss weil was passiert wenn man ein kind
in dem alter unterstützt das alles wird
der medizinisch meinen kindern nichts
gemacht medizinische eingriffe passieren
frühestens eben ab einem gewissen
pubertäts stadium
und deswegen ist es gar nicht so
entscheidend wenn aber andererseits ein
kind seit des zwei jahre alt ist sagt
ich bin das und saß fünf jahre ist in
der rolle lebt dann warum fragt man
diese kinder dann ob sie sich sicher
sind während man dass kinder nicht das
heißt hormonbehandlung und auch
operationen werden erst das passiert
eines deutlich mit deutlich später das
ist jetzt wie ist das eigentlich ich
meine viele aspekte meiner identität
sind instabil also ich habe andere
überzeugen andere wünsche vielleicht
leicht andere charakterzüge aus vor zehn
zwanzig jahren bei der
geschlechtsidentität gibt fälle wo man
sagt irgendwie jemand hat sich über 30
jahre man als über 30 jahre lang als
mann geführt und damals frau oder ist
das eigentlich kommt das eigentlich vor
sondern das bleibt stabil
das ist eine schwierige frage ich meine
es gibt schon menschen die so zender
fluid bezeichnen und das er aus
flüssiger und so gesehen
es ist eines der dogmen in unserer
gesellschaft das geschlecht täglich
zugehörigkeit über das ganze leben
stabil bleibt
ich habe jetzt keine studien die belegen
dass es anders ist aber ich kann das
schon hinterfragen dass auch das etwas
ist was ich im leben ändern kann wie
vieles in der biografie sich geändert
rollenzuschreibungen vatersein mutter
sein großvater großmutter sein
ich glaube wir können fluide denken das
machen andere kulturen auch so sehen sie
das ähnlich als trans personen ist man
ja immer so ein bisschen in der rolle
erst mal die eigene existenz überhaupt
zu verteidigen also ich muss erstmal
allen dermaßen überzeugend erzählen wer
ich bin und völlig glaubwürdig sein in
dem das sich natürlich muss auch dem
gesetz sagen dass ich das nicht mehr
ändern wird also im deutschen
transsexuellen gesetzt da muss ein
gutachter sagen das wird sich
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht mehr ändern
das heißt wir sind wir müssen diese
diese stabilität von identität die
müssen wir schon behaupten damit wir
überhaupt zugang zu den maßnahmen
bekommen die mir gerne hätten sie das
sinnvoll ist diese ärztliche diagnose
brach man ja um den namen ändern zu
können
das eigentlich wie vielleicht und darf
dass das körperliche gefühl dass das ist
nicht das ist nicht sinnvoll also da
gibt es auch studien darüber dass diese
gutachten sowieso zu 95 prozent oder
noch mehr immer genau der selbstaussage
der person entsprechen und das ist
eigentlich inzwischen sind fachlich
gesichert leute wissen welches
geschlecht sie haben jetzt leute genauso
gut die trans leute so und dass andere
diese diese bisher sonneck wird
theoretische oder eine geänderte
politische frage was ist das überhaupt
diese geschlechtsidentität und ist das
überhaupt so stabil wie wir immer
behaupten
das ist sehr spekulativ da wir könnten
wir wissen ja gar nicht genau was
geschlechtsidentität ist und wo sie
herkommt ich will noch interessieren
also ich stelle mir das vor wenn man
wenn man dann dass jetzt dieses coming
out hat das denn ich mir vor wie die
hölle also für für die für sich selbst
premier dann aber auch die beziehung für
freundschaften für
im beruflichen umfeld was muss ich denn
gesellschaftlich ändern damit die dieses
trends seien etwas erträglicher wird
also ist muss ich sehr viel ändern was
sie vor allem ändern muss ist das was
ich als geschlechtliche selbstbestimmung
bezeichnet dass wir selber über unser
geschlecht bestimmen und nicht
irgendwelche expertinnen das braucht auf
der medizinischen ebene ganz neue
behandlungsleitlinien oder empfehlungen
dass wir eigentlich am steuer sitzen und
nicht irgendwelche fachpersonen und
sagen wir zu sein haben
es braucht auf der rechtlichen ebene
kann eine eine liberalisierung es
braucht in der psychiatrie eine 1 and
pathologisierung es braucht im alltag
extrem viele dinge und voran dass das
dass unser weg nicht so mit
behandlungsrichtlinien extrem konzipiert
ist und wir unglaublich viele
anpassungsleistungen und dinge machen
müssen weil das von uns gefordert wird
die selbstbestimmung suspect dass wir
selber wissen wer und was wir sind und
was für uns gut ist für mich ein
wichtiger aspekt vor allem auch in der
medizin und in der psychiatrie
was hat sich da auch schon einiges
geändert in den letzten im letzten
jahrzehnt sage ich mal so ungefähr
und ich finde ein wichtiger punkt ist
noch gesellschaftliche akzeptanz und da
geht es nicht nur darum dass man sagt
okay trans leute gibt und wir lassen die
existieren und leben sondern eigentlich
wäre es zweckmäßig und zwar nicht nur
für trans personen sondern für
eigentlich alle dass diese gestellte
geschlechter schubladen nicht so rigide
wie wir das vorhin mit rosa und hellblau
hatten schon vorgeburtlich vorgezeichnet
werden
ich habe nur im netz den finde ich immer
ganz den ich mal gelesen habe dann finde
ich sehr faszinierend da geht es darum
wie verrückt ist das dass eltern mit
hilfe von kleidung oder auswahl von
kinderzimmer farben allen außenstehenden
sagen mein kind hat das und das genital
ich fand auch noch interessant also
selbst gewisse trans menschen kommen um
diese stereotype ja nicht
also wir haben ein beispiel vorbereitet
aus einem dokfilm das geschlecht der
seele trans menschen in der schweiz im
zweiten teil
da kommt ein trans man vor nick und der
gibt sich mühe dass er eben besonders
männlich aussieht wie sein als das
konnte
für mich ist das kein symbol
vollstrecken
ich weiß noch nichts vom hormon spielt
sowieso des trainings ist eine dichte
bei uns bekommt das ist die zweithöchste
euromonitor welt gebaut und am anfang
ist so ganz anders linken gerade seine
streiche da vinci und das wachstum
gerade macht vielleicht mal gesagt und
nichts über 60 jahren hätte gut
zufrieden gestellt
wenn jetzt ist ein spiegel aber nicht
dass ich dabei und so ist klar so nahmen
lieber als nick als mal dass ich das was
ich wollte sagt sie aber die zeit der
welt schafft frieden brauchen
[Musik]
wenn jetzt einfach so noch 60 einsätze
vielmehr muss kräftemäßig machen bewegt
medien als frau innerlich natürlich auch
einiges verändert das was frau bin ich
extrem nachtragend problem ist es okay
dass ich aufhören mit hormonen
tischkalender hülle
ich danke ich bin extrem viel hätte
würde ich schlimmes extreme verdauen
wenn der proband dann muss ich sagen tut
alle mannschaften also als frau hat die
deutschen kunden kommen hilft ihm auch
die tour de france ist es ist die die
lac du hast dir der markus kurth also
nicht immer gut an oder
ja diesen job führen können sie am
nächsten donnerstag um 20 5 auf sf 1 in
voller länge sehen
herdorf dieser nick beschreibt sich ja
so dass er uns sensibler geworden ist
härter geworden ist können sie das
nachvollziehen
ich habe in der beratung oft mit leuten
zu tun häufig mit partnerin die sich
sorgen machen dass ihr trans man partner
aufgrund der hormone irgendwie so ein
bisschen weniger empathisch wird oder so
und ich sage an der stelle immer wer
kein arschloch werden möchte wird auch
keins natürlich hat home hormonen
einfluss und sie haben auch am einfluss
auf die psyche sicher in irgendeiner art
und weise aber wie sich das auswirkt
schauen sie sich zu männern an
da gibt es alles von donald trump bis
den netten hausmann von nebenan so und
genauso weiß man dass bei trans menschen
auch nicht was sich das auswirkt und ich
glaube diese nature und wirtschaft frage
wann wir haben die möglichkeit unser
verhalten zu beeinflussen und wir haben
auch die möglichkeit unsere hormone zu
ignorieren können wissen was noch zu
wissen was
erziehung ist oder kultur ist die sehen
ja und diese kultur wir leben mit diesen
stereotypen und wird teil pflanzen sie
teilweise auch vor das ist klar weil wir
brauchen eine gewisse sicherheit also
wenn man so lange in ihm geschlecht dass
eine zugewiesen wurde lebt und das einst
diskrepanz ausfall erlebt dass man
vielleicht in die andere richtung
dass noch mehr akzentuiert ich kann das
nachvollziehen
paypal steen hat mal gesagt eine
transaktion ist in einem mail zu viel
mehr to me person und dieses to me finde
ich sehr spannend also von 1 und dann
das andere verstärkt aber letztlich
müssen wir für uns unseren weg finden
und der kunst der typ sein aber er muss
nicht
und das geht klar habe ich auch um
dieses passing halt wenn man natürlich
ist eindeutig an diese stereotype
einschlägt dann fällt man auch nicht als
trans personen auf sondern wird dann
halt als frau gesehen oder aber dass man
dadurch hat man weniger irritationen der
in der öffentlichkeit ja und da machen
wir sehr große anpassungsleistungen aus
einem kollegen hat mit gehört sich
gesagt sie macht es noch eine gesichts
feminisierung ich finde sie sieht
absolut weiblich aus aber sie sagt ich
erlebe das im alltag nicht so ich muss
noch einen schritt weiter gehen und mir
tut es zuweilen schon weh wie viel wir
uns anpassen wie wenig transfer haupt
sichtbar sein dorf im alltag aber ich
verstehe alle die wir unsichtbar sein
wollen weil es eben viel energie braucht
ja möchten denn die meisten trans
personen irgendwann mal eine operation
machen ist das sozusagen der endpunkt
oder kann man auch sagen das sind nur
bestimmte ausnahmen die so weit gehen
möchten wie es da die die regelung
wollen wir die 40.000 nehmen dann ist
das wahrscheinlich im kleinere
prozentsatz die 40.000 dies in der
schweiz gibt
ich weiß gar nicht ob die aktuellen
operationszahlen sind ein paar hundert
oder in der schweiz diesem gemacht
werden aber es ist natürlich schon so
dass man immer das thema trans
thematisiert wird oder thematisiert
werden muss zum beispiel als ein coming
out am arbeitsplatz gibt oder soll ich
das dann in den meisten fällen auch
medizinische angleichung maßnahmen im
spiel sind
das hat wirklich wichtig dieses europa
das ist eben diese ultimative marke und
dann wird immer so getan als sei das
eine freie entscheidung von uns ja es
kann eine wichtige entscheidung sein für
die eigene biografie aber man darf nicht
vergessen dass im transsexuellengesetz
in deutschland das für eine person
stands änderung auch gefordert wurde
nachweis von körperlicher
unfruchtbarkeit in der schweizer
rechtsprechung gab es 2011 das erste
urteil zürcher obergericht das sagte es
braucht keine genitale operation also
wenn man immer so tun als sei das nur
ein freiwilliger weg von trans menschen
und wir sehen die erfüllung nur in
genitalien operationen und dieses thema
so aufbau straße das wichtigste
überhaupt dann vergisst man einfach dass
da auch gesetze dahinter stehen dass da
auch medizin dahinter steht dass da auch
eindruck ist und die ganzen
behandlungsrichtlinien diese richtung
gehen ein kleines beispiel von mir meine
therapeutin nochmal gefragt und wie
sieht es bei ihnen mit der opera mit der
operation aus ich habe gesagt ist im
moment für mich noch kein thema
vielleicht gar nie
ja wieso bleiben sie auf halbem weg
stehen wird fast schon gefordert ich an
dem punkt noch richtig zu ergänzen oder
einfach einen wichtigen punkt noch
zusetzen trans menschen sind einfach
sehr verschieden und diese
gesellschaftliche situationen die finde
ich auch mal echt wichtig zu beleuchten
aber wir haben auch individuelle
situation was den leidensdruck am
eigenen körper betrifft und da gibt's
trans menschen die haben es sehr wenig
leidensdruck oder vielleicht sogar gar
kein die sagen wenn ich eine
gesellschaft leben würde die mich so wie
ich bin als man als frau als nicht
belehren geschlecht akzeptiert dann
würde ich überhaupt nichts machen und es
gibt auf der anderen seite die leute und
das sind halt auch die die bekannte sind
medial und geht auch deswegen immer
wieder so dargestellt werden die ganz
klar sagen für mich stimmt dieses oder
jenes sekundäre geschlechtsmerkmale
nicht das passt nicht das gehört nicht
zu mir oder dir auch wirklich nicht das
vorhaben gegenüber ihrem bartwuchs oder
ich kenne sogar trans männer die sagen
solange ich weiß dass ich diese
eierstöcke habe möchte ich nicht
glücklich
das ist wirklich sehr individuell und
das ist wichtig zu verstehen
das trans nicht bedeutet dann machst du
jetzt alle diese operation dass es da
wirklich die ganze bandbreite gibt und
leute treffen entscheidungen aufgrund
ihrer konkreten bedürfnislage vielfalt
und selbstbestimmung wenig zeit ganz
ganz wichtiger aspekt ich meine
selbstbestimmung ist er heute ein
riesenthema und ein großer wert und auch
wir leben in einer zeit wo viel das
machbar ist was früher nicht möglich
gewesen ist natürlich konditionen wo man
heute gestalten kann ob das am anfang
des lebens ist fortpflanzungsmedizin
oder am ende des lebens oder auch mit
schönheitsoperationen wenn jetzt eine
junge frau fast keine brüste hat und
sich nicht weiblich führen kann da macht
sich eine brust-op gibt es für sie
moralische grenzen auch der eigenen
gestaltbarkeit wo man sagen müsste man
muss bei bestimmten punkt nach lehrern
und sich abzufinden mit dem was gegeben
ist ich setze keine moralischen grenzen
ist nicht an mir jetzt wieder zu
bestimmen
das muss jede person für sich selber
herausfinden wie wie ihr körper wäre
geschlechtlichkeit ihre identität sie
ausgestaltet
wenn wir kultur vergleiche machen zehn
mir auch das ist nicht nur in unserer
kultur ist und jeder kultur so dass auch
körperliche eingriffe gemacht werden
angefangen von tattoos an das geht aber
viel weiter
die gestaltbarkeit des körpers ist ein
zeichen von kultur die eingriffstiefe
hat sich geändert ich glaube das ist der
wichtige punkt das heute vieles möglich
ist was vor jahren noch nicht möglich
war aber das kann auch ein segen sein
ich hatte vor zwei jahren herzoperation
meine güte dieses technische know-how
das ist genial das ist genial
ich finde dir die moralische frage zu
stellen es ganz ganz schwierig wenn man
nicht in der situation ist zum beispiel
wird er auch diskutiert was kann man
alles tun damit leute eigene kinder
kriegen können was gibts ja ganz viele
themen die man besprechen kann
und durch meine eigene erfahrung als
jemand dessen situation nicht
viele leute nachvollziehen können habe
ich gelernt zu sagen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen wie das ist wenn man
unbedingt ein kind haben möchte und man
kriegt keinen ich kann mich da nicht
rein versetzen und ich kann mich auch in
trans leute nicht rein versetzen die
sagen ich muss unbedingt das und das und
das und das auch noch haben an an
medizinischen maßnahmen aber wenn das
bedürfnis da ist und wenn das
bedürfnissen leidensdruck verursacht da
diskutieren wir ja bei anderen
eingriffen auch nicht ob wir zur
gesunderhaltung der leute was machen nur
nicht genau das finde ich ganz ganz gut
erklärt ich habe mich im sinne eines
danken experiments noch gefragt ob es
andere bereiche gibt wo nicht unser
körper die körperlichen merkmale
entscheidend sind sondern das innere
wissen und bei trans identen personen
ist das ja so könnte man jetzt wirklich
nur hass spekulatives gedankenexperiment
zum beispiel auch hautfarbe nationalität
alter aus angenommen ich würde jetzt
sagen ich fühle mich wie 20
sie behauptet oder dann wäre man so alt
wie man sich fühlt man streicht das
geburtsdatum außen passt jetzt nur maus
überlegung ist es dieser vergleich nicht
zu machen
ich finde den vergleich der leidensdruck
ist natürlich umfangreich mann und ich
finde den vergleich deswegen schwierig
zu machen weil es man kann natürlich
bestimmte parallelen so gedanken
spielerisch machen aber gerade zum
beispiel hautfarbe oder nationalität da
haben wir ähnlich wie bei geschlecht wir
haben ganz klar im machtgefälle bei
geschlecht haben wir einerseits ist als
norm und trans als diejenigen die sich
erklären müssen
wir haben aber auch männer auf der einen
seite und frauen als diejenigen die noch
ein bisschen schlechter gestellt sind
bei hautfarbe ist das ganz klar wir
leben in einer strukturellen
rassistischen gesellschaft aber ich
würde mich jetzt sträuben über das thema
in dem rahmen zu diskutieren weil ich
glaube eine schwarze person die da vor
dem bildschirm sitzt du denkst sind die
jetzt verrückt geworden über über trans
rasse oder trans race zu sprechen
da gibt es aber es gibt diese debatte es
gibt sie debatte und es gibt solche und
diesen berühmten fall genau da hat sich
die schwarze community ganz entschieden
dagegen gewehrt
genau aber dann will ich nicht die
person trug zum drüber sprechen
ich würde vorschlagen dass wir jetzt
noch über diese zwischentöne sprechen
die sie angesprochen haben also über
menschen die biologisch nicht eindeutig
mann oder frau sind das hormonell ist
genetisch anatomisch sogenannte
intersexuelle menschen aber auch dem
diesen binären menschen die vielleicht
körperlich eindeutig sind aber vom der
geschlechtsidentität vom gefühl er sich
dazwischen befinden und wir haben ja
auch einen einspieler vorbereitet trans
menschen kommen zwar mit dem für sie
falschen geschlecht zur welt jedoch mit
einem biologisch eindeutigen
unterscheiden muss man trans menschen
darum von inter geschlechtlichen
menschen und von sogenannten binären
menschen die man auch gender ku band der
reihe nach jährlich kommen in der
schweiz rund 40 menschen auf die welt
deren geschlecht sich nicht eindeutig
biologisch einordnen lässt also inter
geschlechtliche menschen davon gibt es
verschiedene formen und ausprägungen
auch diesen menschen wird aber derzeit f
oder als amtliches geschlecht zugewiesen
manchmal zeigt sich aber erst in der
pubertät dass zb die inneren
geschlechtsorgane nicht entwickelt sind
früher wurden schon im kleinst
kindesalter geschlechts zu weisende
operationen gemacht ohne dass der
betroffene selber über seine gefühlte
geschlechtsidentität urteilen konnte
heute werden solche kleinkinder nur noch
bei anatomischer notwendigkeit operiert
neben inter geschlechtlichen menschen
gibt es auch menschen die trotz
eindeutigem körperlichen geschlecht sich
weder klar männlich noch klar weiblich
fühlen menschen also die sich nicht in
das herkömmliche streng zweigeteilte
geschlechter modell einordnen menschen
mit dem dritten oder non binären
geschlecht
nicht man nicht frau so fühlt sich auch
die hübsche ein xmp us-stadt f oder em
würde free hübscher sich wünschen für
eine binäre und inter geschlechtliche
menschen die gesellschaft sind manche
monate eigentlich unüblich sind können
mit minute vor dass die diesen wiener
taxi stand und dass das zeigt sich zwar
nicht gegen aufs wc bett und sagt ich
bin mit frau ich bin nicht arrogant wie
das wetter morgen kratzten irgendwie bis
neutrales aber sehr oft nicht unser
wieder und und wann mir jetzt zum
beispiel dass es im haus wo ihr andere
landen schon dort sache ich war mal dass
in der schweiz hätte dann würde so
einfach wie heißt er ja doch jetzt gibt
es gibt so ist es existieren und und
momentan ist einfach oft so dass sich
formen oder und ich gehen muss für da
muss ich immer zwischen herr und frau an
dass wir ganz einfach ist das andere
es wäre einfach das zu ändern ein
exemplars auch im alltag stelle ich mir
das ehrlich gesagt schwierig vor wie
spricht man eine solche person an mit er
oder sie pianist pianistin wie sehen sie
das
die sprache spielt uns natürlich schon
einen streich wenn wir nun minorität
denken und fördern auch aussprechen
wollen weil unsere sprache ist
hochgradig pina neue sprachformen
überhaupt weg von der die also wie im
englischen da gibt es das auch nicht
ich selber stoße immer wieder ein
bisschen an meine grenzen was nun bei
mary betrifft weil ich bin irgendwie
näher ich habe viele dinge gemacht und
das irgendwo wieder in einklang zu
bringen
bin aber doch nicht bei ihnen im alltag
ist ob alle auf die straße auch
sprachlich an meine grenzen wenn ich auf
all diese begriffe die wir zu ordnen
männlich war habe ich wenn ich auf die
verzichte es braucht für mich eine
unglaubliche denkleistung ich glaube das
geht allen so aber auch hier die frage
des respekts gegenüber nicht binäre
menschen
eine eine sensibilisierung sprache
voraus und vor ort eine neue lösung
dafür aber man könnte ja sagen warum
eigentlich noch ein drittes geschlecht
facebook hat der 60 geschlechter ich
würde gerne auf das sprachlich noch mal
eingehen weil es gibt natürlich
praktisch und in summe also was nun
binäre menschen zum beispiel häufig
machen dass sie anstelle er oder sie
jeweils ihren namen oder eine kurzform
von ihrem namen benutzen also dass sie
dann nicht sagen wie sam das ist sein
etwa sondern es heißt sam das sms at me
also das ist eine variante
und ganz wichtig ist es und da wünsche
ich mir tatsächlich auch noch ein stück
gesellschaftlicher entwicklung die schon
angefangen hat dass wir eben nicht
sehr geehrte damen und herren sagen
sondern liebes publikum oder die
menschen vor dem fernseher das einfach
klar wird es ist da noch nicht fertig
bei den damen und den herren und
sprachlich kann man das auch so machen
dass man sagt expertin mit so einem
kleinen zwischenraum dazwischen oder
schüler in oder lehrer ins gesicht ich
da sagen unterstrich das sind die beiden
sachen wie man das schriftlich machen
kann und das hat auch den vorteil dass
das kürzer ist als zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer über zuschauer innen
wir werden sehen wie das das benutzt
wird mit der dritten option ich finde
das als politisches signal sehr wichtig
dass ein intersex mensch dieses dieses
urteil erfordern hat mit großen
anstrengung und das ist diese dritte
option jetzt mal gibt weil es für mich
in deutschland genau er springt für mich
mal einfach dieses feste zwei
geschlechter chor sein aber was ist dann
wenn man auch das geschlecht wenn das
irgendwann mal unwichtigen werden da gar
nichts drin steht das wäre aber es war
viel einfacher es gibt diesen diese news
professor der genau darum dafür plädiert
dass man dass das amtliche geschlechter
im pass abschafft und sagt es gibt
eigentlich keinen grund warum es das
geben sollte
ich meine was bin ich philosophisch
interessant ist oder wahrnehmungs
theoretisch dass unser blick immer
einsehen als ist immer schon
kategorisieren ist wasser man sieht
jemanden als frau als mann
und jetzt wird eine dritte kategorie
geschaffen als nicht bin ich weiß nicht
sehen sie solche menschen wie die
hübsche schon aus nicht ist das eine
neue kategorie bei ihnen geworden
man kann nun realität genau so wenig
sehen wie trans das essen das ist ein
irrtum
also es kann sein dass das irgendjemand
der ihnen hier im haus begegnet nun bin
ist das können sie nicht von außen sehen
bei cree sieht man jetzt eine gewisse
androgynität so im äußeren aber das ist
längst nicht bei allen binären menschen
und sie werden nicht erfahren ob eine
person bin er ist solange die ihnen das
nicht sagt schließlich diese antwort an
kannst du nicht besser sagen ja also ich
finde das schon interessant dass man
irgendwie genau es ist eine innere
aktualität geht in diesen fragen was man
isst alles spricht dafür alle indizien
von außen sprechen dafür dass dieses
kind ein junge ist trotzdem wertete sie
dass sie eine frau ist
das finde ich schon spannend als das
nicht aus einfach das beispiel davon von
geschlechtsidentität oder vertrauens
menschen also eigentlich ist es
eigentlich ist das was diese trans
kinder als letzten satz gesagt haben das
trans mädchen
wir müssen begreifen dass es mädchen
gibt die mps haben und dass es jungen
gibt diene wagner haben so einfach ist
es
daraus ergibt sich ganz ganz viel
anderes daraus ergibt sich dass das
biologische geschlecht nicht maßgeblich
ist daraus ergibt sich dass zum beispiel
die frage schwangerschaft oder kinder
zeugen nicht an männlichkeit und
weiblichkeit gekoppelt sein muss per se
daraus ergibt sich ziemlich viel das ist
ein sehr radikale gedanken aber der
körper spielt er dennoch eine
schlüsselrolle weil ganz radikal und ich
ja sagen ich könnte mich als frau fühlen
aber ich möchte weder wie eine frau
aussehen wie eine typische noch nicht so
verhalten das wäre doch irgendwie auch
nicht das ist so überraschend wenn sie
wirklich wenn sie sagen ich bin eine
frau ich trete aber im alltag als man
auf und für wo niemand recht für mich
soweit wohl in meinem körper ich weiß
einfach dass das so ist dann könnte
auch sein dass sie sagen ich fand es
toll wenn in zukunft weibliche pronomen
benutzt werden oder so was
aber sie könnten auch komplett darauf
verzichten auf den zirkus und einfach
wissen wer sie sind und trotzdem hätten
sie alles recht von leuten die sie
kennen als ernst genommen zu werden als
frau man könnte ich dann auch mein
eigentliches geschlecht ende und und den
namen ende
es wird wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
schwierig das durchzukriegen weil die
gerichte verlangen in der regel oder
verlangen häufig noch so gewisse
körperliche maßnahmen und ich weiß nicht
auf meinem den gender marke erinnern
kann ohne ohne den vornamen zu ändern
also sozusagen ob es möglich ist obwohl
ihr für die sich zum beispiel noch
anbieten für beides das aber das ist im
prinzip möglich ja eigentlich gibt es
keinen grund das irgendwie nicht zu
beweisen aber es ist im alltag natürlich
relativ kompliziert dann mit einem
weiblichen pass rumzulaufen dieses
posting hofft man dann natürlich nicht
als wenn man sie genau es ja das machen
was immer wieder diese irritation sie
hätten dann das gleiche bild leben was
trans menschen haben die ihren pass und
ihren sender aus einem grund noch nicht
ändern konnte das ist für mich ein ganz
wichtiger aspekt im thema für mich es
hat diese vielfalt aspekt extrem wichtig
dass er mein lieblingszitat diesem
bereich von einem transporter
amerikanische hat mal gesagt denn dieser
universe an wie all stars an dem trend
to pinpoint mein constellation das
gefällt mir gut weil es diese vielfalt
aspekt hat und auch zeigt es ist etwas
was wir selber für uns bestimmen können
müssen schränkt pinpoint mai
constellation das ist auch eigentlich
mein thema seit ich lebe meine
konstellation zu finden
dass es für mich stimmt dass ich mich
wohl fühle und das sind
unterschiedlichste wege das sind alle
menschen alle trans menschen extrem
unterschiedlich auch nun beim wiener
auch wenn das sie vielleicht im moment
sehr schwer vorstellbar ist aber ich
habe man ihn nach den schönen satz
gelesen es gibt so viele geschlechter
wie es menschen ist das standardformat
bisschen schwer es ist sagt sehen sie
das endlich individuellen geschlechter
fingerabdruck
assistent von rudi haring ich glaube da
könnte ich mich inhaltlich anschließen
ich finde es aber noch mal wichtig ein
punkt noch klar zu machen weil das
häufig auch so vermischt wird
wenn wir über non bisher reden dann
sprechen wir über identität das heißt
eben egal wie eine person aussieht egal
was sie mit ihrem körper tut oder macht
oder nicht macht
denn er bedeutet ich identifiziere mich
weder als mann noch als frau jedenfalls
nicht stabil und dauerhaft
es gibt auch nur ein binäre leute die
wechseln so denn der fluid oder so das
feld mit in dem bereich oder es gibt
leute die sagen ich habe gar kein
geschlecht was die aber machen wie sie
leben was sie von der soziale rolle
ausfüllen oder so das wissen wir nicht
das ist neu denn er bezieht sich
wirklich nur auf die identität und um
nochmal auf ihrem beispiel zu kommen
wenn sie plötzlich feststellen dass sie
sich als frau identifizieren
dann sind sieben er egal was sie machen
genau machen dann sind sieben er
geschlechtlich und nicht die tatsache
dass sich sozial das geschlecht bin
körperlich das mache oder nicht mache
macht mich zu das ist das ist so ein
punkt der oft vermischt wird dass man
sagt so leute die nur bestimmte
eingriffe machen sind dann vielleicht
nun bin ich habe in der anderen
operation gesagt dass das trans menschen
immer noch diskriminiert werden
stigmatisiert werden was wäre der
nächste schritt den wir jetzt aus
schweiz machen müssen aus ihrer sicht
wichtig wäre ein
antidiskriminierungsgesetz zu haben für
für geschlechtsidentität und ja genau
bei der gelegenheit auch für sexuelle
orientierung weil das gibt es auch noch
nicht also was es gibt die sachen
rassismus durch diese antirassismus
strafnorm genau das ist schon ein
längeres politisches thema das wäre gut
das man einfach angriffe auf grund
dessen wirklich auch so ahnen kann und
so anzeigen kann man sich auch so aus
diskriminierungsgesetz absolut wichtig
dass wir einen besseren zugang zum
gesundheitssystem haben wir es immer
noch nicht so gut wie er sein kann dass
wir da auch respektvoll behandelt werden
so wie wir das möchten finde ich extrem
wichtig darum sind wir beide auch in der
fachgruppe trans und die
behandlungssituation die gesundheits das
gesundheitssystem
trans freundlicher zu machen ich hatte
bis jetzt glück hab ich keine stories
von freundinnen da stehen mir ich habe
zwar keine aber die haare zu berge die
körper also auch in der medizin ist noch
viel möglich in den
behandlungsempfehlungen ist viel möglich
auf der gesetzlichen ebene
antidiskriminierung in der psychiatrie
für mich die frage der entpolitisierung
kommen wir da raus oder brauchen wir das
damit wir überhaupt kassenleistungen
bekommen und das ist auch eine wichtige
frage die ihn wieder kommt dass es sind
noch sehr sehr viele fragen vor allem
auch wie ich eben auf der
gesellschaftlichen ebene weil wir sind
immer in diesem in diesem zwiespalt
darin einerseits bestimmte anforderungen
zu genügen damit wir überhaupt überleben
können und andererseits sind wir genau
in diesem ist in diesem doppelband das
wie rechtsanwalt werden mit mit
unmöglichen oder nicht erfüllbaren
anforderungen die uns auch extrem viel
schwierigkeiten machen ja philosophie
das ist immer auch der versuch einen
perspektivenwechsel zu machen und ich
finde das ist heute gut gelungen
vielen herzlichen dank herr rudolf frey
baeriswyl für dieses gespräch
ja nächste woche spielen wir die frage
weiter was eigentlich unsere identität
bestimmt
barbara bleisch spricht mit dem
philosophen und literaten ijoma mangold
darüber was das heißt schwarz zu sein
und wie unsere herkunft und prägt und am
17 februar zeichen wir wieder einen
philosophischen stammtisch auf im lokal
sud in basel
seien sie live dabei und sichern sie
sich jetzt die letzten plätze für die
aufzeichnung jetzt gleich gehts weiter
mit einem porträt über daniel schwarz
ein faszinierender film über den
schweizer fotografen der uns von der
chinesischen mauer bis nach pakistan
führt horizont erweiterung im besten
sinne also genießen sie den sonntag
ja
[Musik]
hallo